لا يخفى على الناس في بريطانيا ان القطاع
الصحي يمر بازمه شديده عده حلول طرحت من
اجل التخفيف من وطاتها كوضع مسؤوليه وصف
بعض الادويه على عاتق صيدليات كهذه فهل
ينتقل عبر الازمه الصحيه من المستشفيات
الى الصيدليات
طرحنا هذا السؤال على الصيدلي عمر زاهر
الذي يكاد يخلو يومه من ساعه راحه اذ يدخل
هذه الصيدليه ما لا يقل عن 100 شخص يوميا
واذا ما قمنا بعمليه حسابيه بسيطه نرى ان
عمليه صرف الادويه تستغرق ما بين عشر
دقائق الى نصف ساعه وبالتالي المزيد من
المسؤوليات والمزيد من ساعات العمل
والمزيد من الحاجه لايض عامل جديده
كيف بده يمشي هذا الموضوع كيف بدنا ننسق
بالوقت نحن اولريدي اوفر يعني مضغوطين
كتير هل يا ترى في فان دينك وراح يكون في
مجال للترينينج راح يكون فيه يعني لحتى
ينعمل له ينعمل هذا الموضوع بشكل صحيح بس
في بريطانيا ينتظر اكثر من سبعه ملايين
مريض موعدا مع طبيب لكن مع الخطه الجديده
تحاول الحكومه تمرير بعض اعباء نظام الصحه
الوطنيه الى الصيدليات فمريض الانفلونزا
مثلا بامكانه رؤيه الصيدلاني بدلا من
الطبيب العام ليس صيدليتك عندي عندما ساحه
معينه يمكن ممكن تاخدي جزء منها لتعمليه
مش مشكله بس التوظيف والتمرين صيادلي ما
بيقدروا يتحملوه وهنا هو البيت القصيد هل
يا ترى الدوله راح تقول له للصيدله لانه
انت عمول هذا الموضوع او هن راح يكون
عندهم التمويل لحتى يساعدونا فيه
15 مليون موعد طبي خلال العامين المقبلين
لكن البعض يرى ان هذه الخطه ترحل الازمه
من قطاع المستشفيات الى صيدليات من لندن
عروب عبد الحق العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات